- Hey, everybody!
(audience cheers)
I'm a hugger.
- I know! We're both
Southern, we're both huggers,
but then I got afraid
'cause I'm showing my arms
and I'm super white so they painted them
and you have a pretty white blouse on.
- Wouldn't you take Kelly's
tan all over you, people?
We'll take that.
- It's great to see you again.
- You too, thanks for having me.
- Absolutely, thank you for coming.
How are you doing?
- Everything is so good.
Just the kids, I got two
out of the house now,
one at home, so Kelly,
I've got time on my hands.
I can be here at any time.
- You only have one kid now
in your home.
- Only one.
- Wow!
- And I miss them so much.
The house is so quiet.
- Yeah.
- I'm gonna come
to your house for bath time.
- Is it kinda nice though?
Do you get to read now again?
- I do, I read these things called books.
- Yeah.
- Right?
- I love when people are
like "What do you read?"
And I'm like, "Still the same novel".
- I've got the same one on my nightstand,
it's so funny.
- 'Cause I can't get
through it 'cause there's just not
enough time.
- I miss where you are,
though at that stage, I miss bath time.
I'm sort of feeling nostalgic for it all.
- Oh my gosh.
Well, my kids are very
independent at this point.
They love doing it alone now.
They're five and seven,
so they're they're like,
"No, no Mom, we got it."
And they love being able
to do their whole routine
and I support independence, so yeah.
I read my shows while they're
doing that, I'm like cool.
- And then my son who's at home,
he's a freshman in high school.
This is all my husband and
I do, is just stare at him.
I mean, he gets home,
like it's just us staring,
so yes.
- He's the youngest?
- We miss the lively of
the house, but it's good.
- That's awesome, and
now you're gonna start
preparing for whenever he goes.
- Right?
- Yeah.
- Four years goes like that.
You will see this, and
any parent out here knows,
elementary school goes slow,
like first through eighth
grade, you're like, huh,
high school flies by just like college.
- [Kelly] I think it all flies by.
- Yeah.
- They're like,
I just look at pictures and it seems
like such a cliche to
say, but it just flies by.
- It goes so quick.
- Yeah, yeah.
Well, you recently posted
this and it's awesome,
so we wanna show it.
(Kit laughs)
- [Kit] Like, take it in people!
- First of all, is that a real tan?
'Cause that's a good tan!
- Let's be clear, that's 1988,
there was no self tanners back then.
That is baby oil and laying out
on my roof in Atlanta, Georgia.
- Oh my gosh!
- Which is why I've got,
yeah, that's not good, you
should not be applauding!
That's no sunscreen in the '80s.
And how about the bad white taffeta dress?
Do you like the banana clip?
- Bad? That is amazing!
- Or the choker?
- [Kit] The choker, Kelly!
- That's amazing!
I'm taking it all in.
- Zinc pink.
- [Kelly] Zinc pink?
- Yeah, remember that lipstick?
Can you hear the John
Hughes soundtrack playing?
- That's why I love it.
- That's "Pretty in Pink",
baby, right there, yeah.
And those are my two best
friends from elementary school.
Oh, that's Noodle and Goose.
We blurred them out, but-
- Noodle and Goose!
Oh my gosh, it's like you're
on "Top Gun" or something.
So wait, so what do you
remember about that night?
- Well, Brett Baier was my prom date.
I don't know if y'all
watch Fox News Channel?
Yeah, so he was my prom
date, but he was a golfer
so he came late, so I just met him there,
but we had just so much fun.
I loved everybody in my high school.
I had the best group of friends that we're
still friends with.
- Oh, I had a great
group of friends, yeah.
I wouldn't like repeat it,
but I had a great time.
- I think so, like-
- Yeah, I enjoyed it the one time.
- The one time, the one time
through, but I don't know.
I just thought the tunes were
great, the fashion was great.
- So what, you were voted
most athletic, okay.
Me too, so weird.
- [Kit] We know Kelly won
the sports Emmy, okay, so.
- I won two, Kit!
(both women laugh)
(laughing) I love that
you gave me sports Emmys!
- Please tell me they're
right in your dining room?
- I will not change them.
- Forever, yes.
- Yeah, but I have to ask,
I did actually love
playing sports growing up,
so what was your favorite sport?
- So for me, I went to college
on a running scholarship,
so I loved, well, I
didn't really love to run,
let's be clear about that.
I just kind of excelled at it,
but I loved basketball, softball, tennis,
soccer were kinda like-
- Oh, you were super athletic!
- And then I was the first one
at every slumber party
to fall asleep early,
'cause I was just exhausted.
So I was the one that all
the pranks got played on
in a great way, and I loved
them all, like the hand
in the hot water.
- The hand in the water
to get you to pee?
- Yes!
- I just thought of that.
- I was the best one!
- Oh my god!
I was the one who could outlast
everyone, I'm a night owl.
- You were the night owl.
- [Kelly] I was putting
your hand in the cup.
- You were, and by the
way, I would've loved it.
I woke up like, "You got me again!"
- (laughing) It's awesome,
if you haven't tried it
on someone.
I mean, don't do that,
that's horrible.
- That's horrible, be nice.
- Speaking of sports though,
so you also play, I
don't know what this is,
but pickle ball?
- Does anybody know pickle ball out here?
It is sweeping the nation!
- What? How am I the only
- Wait, Kelly that's my son.
person that doesn't know pickle
ball?
- By the way, who's six feet
tall now, that's a whole
nother weird thing.
14 and weird.
- Oh my god, they grow.
- Okay, pickle ball you
need to play with your kids.
- Okay.
- It is a mixture
of ping pong, badminton,
you don't have to be athletic at all.
I just played with a second grader
and I played with my mom who's 82.
Anybody can play, there's a small paddle,
the court's like half the size
or quarter of a size of a tennis court.
- Okay.
- It's just something fun
to do outdoors and you
laugh your face off.
- Oh my god, I'm just still trying
to put those two games together
that you just mentioned in my head.
- Badminton, so it's a badminton ball
and kind of like a bigger
paddle than in ping pong.
- Oh okay, so that's what
you're hitting it with.
- But you will have so
much fun with your kids.
I'm gonna send you some pickle ball stuff.
It'll be so fun to play
for somebody competitive
and for all you out there,
it kinda taps into
something inside of you.
I don't know, it's really
fun and not hard at all.
- [Kelly] Okay, I'm down.
- I got you.
- I do think I heard though
- It's a big deal.
- when I heard about this
that Lisa, my teleprompter goddess,
you play pickle ball, right Lisa?
(audience laughs)
Oh hi, there we go!
- Hi sweets!
Your team over here is so nice.
- She's awesome, and also if you want
really awesome cookies, Lisa's your girl.
She says, "Care for a
match?", so I'm just saying,
- Guys!
- yes!
- You could play it
right here on set, Kelly,
you could easily set up one.
If you've got the paddles here,
we could go out with them.
- (laughing) Oh wait, wait!
Lisa said, "Great! I will destroy you!"
- I like her already!
(Kelly laughs)
Listen, Lisa!
- [Kelly] Listen Lisa!
- I'm a big dill!
- Listen, Lisa.
- Pickle.
- Lisa, if you play,
you have to absolutely bring
some of your cookies for Kit.
So, do your kids ever get embarrassed
of anything you've
done, like in your past?
Like, recently my daughter was like,
"I saw a video of you and you
have a crop top shirt on",
and she's seven so she's
like, "I can show my tummy",
and I'm like, "No, you can't!
'Cause I was paying my bills!"
- They're embarrassed by my existence.
Like, everything I do embarrasses my kids.
I'm not allowed to post them on my story.
Like, you saw my son there,
but I have to get permission.
No Christmas card, I can't post because,
but if you think about it,
if your mom was posting you
when you were a teenager,
you wouldn't like that,
what pictures I might choose, so.
- I'm kind of the person that makes fun
of myself first though,
so I think I'd post it
before anyone else.
- Yeah, well,
the one thing too, all three kids,
my favorite quality besides being nice,
self-deprecation, they
can laugh at themselves.
- That's awesome!
- And they love to laugh
at mom, which is my favorite thing,
so they troll me on social media.
If you follow me, their
comments are always the best.
They're like, oh, working out,
I was in my garage over COVID,
working out, we set up a gym.
Well, gym, we use that term
loosely, there's like a mat.
And so I'm on the mat and there's a mirror
and I post a picture
and my daughter's like,
"What is with all your
clothes from TJ Maxx
in front of the stupid mirror?"
And I said, "No, no,
these are Kirkland baby!"
- These are Kirkland!
- And they're like, "You
need to up your game, Mom!"
Do you know what I mean?
And so they're constantly trolling
and they're like, "What is your face?"
And there's that app
- I love that.
- that you can swipe that's
called the Paris filter,
and it makes you blurry.
- I don't know that.
- So all my pictures are slightly blurry.
- I think that app is just a natural thing
that happens when you drink
at a bar late at night.
(Kit laughs)
- I live for Paris!
- Beer goggles.
- Yeah, which is so funny.
- So wait, what about though,
'cause you were on MTV "Road Rules",
so I know you had to do like crazy stuff.
You're athletic, I know you
had to do athletic things
like that.
- I thought that's why
they hired me for that,
but clearly they didn't.
I don't know what that was.
- You also happen to be beautiful as well,
so that was maybe one reason too.
But it is a competitive thing though,
and you love to compete,
but I know that you wanted to do fun stuff
because wait, I wanna show this tape,
and I just imagine my
daughter watching my video
in my crop top and your
kids watching that.
- They loved it.
- Wait.
- [Kit] But you know what? Actually...
It's kind of nice not having clothes.
- [Man] It really is.
- I just wasn't thrilled
about getting naked
in front of some 70 year old naked man
and sitting in the jacuzzi with him.
(water bubbling)
(audience cheers)
Yeah!
- Oh my god!
My favorite part of the video is actually
I get made fun of so much for saying
neck-ed.
- Neck-ed.
- Everybody makes fun of me for saying,
that's how you say it.
You know what sounds more hillbilly?
Naked.
- Naked!
- You would never say pajama, naked.
No, it's neck-ed.
- Naked sounds like you
may mate with your family.
- Yes!
You don't go there.
- Naked sounds worse to me!
Weiss is like, "Too far" (laughs).
- Bring it in, bring it in.
By the way I had to get
the clue and get naked
in the jacuzzi with the
nice old fella 'cause
I'm competitive.
- Nice old fella?
- And so I needed the clue!
- You made it nicer, you said nice,
but on the video you were like,
"I didn't wanna get naked
with this 70 year old man."
- My kids were like, "You're so Southern",
but at the time I'd never
lived out of the South.
That was by the way, 27 years ago.
How much fun?
No such thing as reality TV.
I would do it again
tomorrow, I had so much fun.
- Well, I think that you have
the personality for it too.
That's why you excelled at it.
- It would be like you,
you and me on a road trip.
I couldn't get the conception of it.
Like you're gonna pay
me to go on a road trip?
And like we're sponsored by Taco Bell
and I love Budweiser and it
was just a dream come true.
- So wait, you co-hosted
"Access Hollywood"
with your husband Crowley
recently, so how did that go?
Was it fun or terrifying?
- First of all, there he is.
So Crowley Sullivan, my
husband, he was so funny, y'all,
because I've been on
this show for 12 years,
we talked about this,
to get hired at age 40
and I'll be 52 this year.
- Yeah.
- So he sits down
and he's like, "Oh, so this
is what you've been doing
with your time."
Like nobody in my family cares.
- They don't watch?
- They don't watch,
they don't know what I
do, you know what I mean?
That's kinda nice.
- I love it.
- Yeah, 'cause then you just
have a family home.
- We've made sure the kids
are the stars, it's all about them.
And I remember once I was
covering the Golden Globes
and I was sort of feeling
myself 'cause I had these lashes
and my fake hair in and
I'm like coming home.
- You're like, so wonderful.
- And quickly, side note,
that was the day that I got Brad Pitt.
Y'all, I'm walking on the red
carpet, I bump into Brad Pitt.
I panic and I say to him,
"Hey Brad, Kit Pitt".
And like I'm not Kit Pit.
And he says, "Maiden or married?"
And I was like oh my
god, he's talking back!
I said maiden, and he goes,
"There's not many of us in there",
and he starts talking to me.
Then I say, "I love architecture."
(women talk over one another)
And then they pull him away.
But anyway, so I had a Pitt moment.
- I love your random things!
Kit Pitt and I love architecture.
- Exactly, 'cause apparently I read
in an article that he likes architecture.
It went south quickly, but I
get home and I'm feeling myself
and I'm in my dress and literally
the whole family's like,
"Mom, what's for dinner?
Are you gonna make your parma rosa?"
And like, I couldn't
have loved it any more,
like nobody really cares
about my day job.
- I love that.
- Yeah.
- My kids look at me
'cause I don't wear hair and makeup
- Ever.
- if I'm not working.
- Yes.
- I have to be paid
to do this.
- Yes.
- 'Cause I'm allergic as well,
so it stings, the eye makeup.
I love you, Glo!
But I love my makeup artist, though,
but I, when I get home, my
son, especially he freaks out.
He's like, "Can you take a shower?"
'Cause it freaks him
out, 'cause he's like,
"I don't like you in that."
He was like, I like you,
and I'm, that's so nice.
- I know, my kids are like that.
My husband's the opposite.
'Cause on the weekend I'm
baseball hat, no makeup.
He was like, "Where's that Monday through
Friday lady?"
- This is false advertisement.
- Yeah, exactly!
Could that lady with the
lashes ever come home,
and I'm like beat with my hat on.
- And you're like, no,
you're lucky (laughs).
So wait, what do you love most
about doing "Access" these days?
'Cause you've been doing it for a bit.
- For a bit.
I think we've started
interviewing a lot of
normal people; by normal,
I mean not celebrities
- Yeah.
- with extraordinary stories
and I find myself so moved by them.
- Yeah.
- I don't know if it's my age
or where I am now, but
there are so many times
that I'm blown away by the human strength,
and that's why I like the
Olympics and everything
watching that story, the human spirit.
- Yeah.
- So those are the stories
that are moving me but I'm
just having a ball.
- I think we need
them more now too,
that's why I like it too.
- Don't you?
- This show came at such
a perfect time for me and my
crew because it's like, yeah,
I like interviewing the celebrities,
I like doing it, but it's really cool.
You get to highlight these
people doing amazing things
and then you get to see the
positive side of humanity,
'cause it can get real dark, real quick.
- You're doing one today, I
was listening to the team.
What are we doing in Vegas?
Like I heard that and that's
what moves me these days.
- I know, it's incredible.
People are actually thinking
of others, it's awesome.
- Yeah, how about that thing?
- It's a good idea.
- Yeah, it's a good idea.
- Well, we need another break,
so you can see Kit host "Access Hollywood"
and "Access Daily".
Check your local listings
for where to watch.